foreign
oh you know what I'm really trying to
work on for myself this year
I my angst and my impulsive replying on
emails anyone do bad email replies I I
actually were a class because
some people write emails so
professionally and just beautifully and
I want to share this little story so I
remember when it was pouring rain last
month that Monday it was just and it was
I know the rain in my okay I I don't
mean to brag but yeah I have a condo
good job for Melissa you know property
thank you
but
um so but I share I share walls and I
share my neighbor and I both had the
leaks were coming through the wallpaper
and the water was coming under the
kitchen doors and I was like oh [__] so
I emailed my neighbor and she's having
the same problem and I was like we
better tell HOA about this homeowners
association
and I said they better not Mickey Mouse
this on us and I was like she probably
thinks like what the [__] is she talking
about but
Mickey Mouse Sing it is like doing a
half-assed job on something on your and
your house
um
and I thought then I thought about I
mean I heard that growing up from my
parents when I'm like why Mickey he's
successful you know he's done a really
good job oh that's right
but it should be goofy if anyone you
know don't goof it up
okay anyway
I want to get to the email
so my neighbor writes a beautiful email
to the HOA and I'd like to read it for
you and then I'm going to read you mine
okay
hi Leia just putting this at the top of
your inbox as we enter a new week
to follow up to what Melissa has
requested we need the following bullet
point she used bullet points
I didn't know you could do that anyway a
qualified Roofing deck specialist to
locate the source of the leak
I have been working with August Roofing
and National deck and stairs we have
them also work on Melissa's unit as I
assume the same companies did her
Roofing deck is there a record of this
bullet point two a qualified contractor
to redo our damaged Interiors walls
ceiling doors and flooring who can you
assign to do this work and when can they
come out to begin
as someone who has had this issue since
2021 I want to ensure that we aren't
getting Patchwork but quality long-term
repairs as Patrick does not solve the
issue and when the next rainfall comes
the leaks happen again and we're back to
square one if we can get a quality job
done now we ideally put these issues
past us thank you comma Sam beautiful
that's just so nice good for her
ready for mine
who do you have to redo while that's
cracked and warped door as well as do a
good job fixing roof flooring HOA should
cover this no period no thank you no
Melissa
I'm ashamed and embarrassed
[Laughter]
and then ahoa emailed back two bullet
points the first one to Samantha we will
we will hire a qualified Roofing deck
specialist to locate the source of the
leak Samantha bullet point two for
Melissa are you okay
I I hate that about myself I hate that I
do that